one way to figure out what science is
about is to look up the term in
prominent scientific sites dictionaries
and encyclopedias
now it may not be necessary to research
all sources because they all pretty much
say the same thing
here we're going to look at two
locations two sites nasa
and the collins dictionary
[Music]
according to nasa
science consists of observing the world
by watching listening observing and
recording
science is curiosity in thoughtful
action about the world and how it
behaves
for its part
collins dictionary defines science as
the study of the nature and behavior of
natural things and the knowledge that we
obtain about them
so what happens if after observing
watching
listening
observing some more
recording and studying nature
we obtain no knowledge
does the student graduate as a scientist
we argue instead that science is about
proposing rational explanations for how
the universe works
this is the goal of science and this is
what laymen want to understand
it doesn't matter how much a researcher
has observed watched or listened
or how many hours they studied
if what comes out of the assembly line
are irrational explanations
what have we learned
what was all the studying for
what we need to do now
is define what we mean by rational and
explanation
[Music]
you